- Rolling Stone
put out an article.
It was something like
NBA's anti-vaxxer problem,
and they're pushing around the
league, and all that stuff.
And I had a call
with a journalist,
and it was all good faith,
oh, Jonathan, would love to
get your story, all this stuff,
and I'm telling him
about why my decision
not to get vaccinated.
And then the article
comes out and it's like,
Jonathan Isaac waited
for people to die,
he put his trust in God,
all this different stuff.
I'm like, this is terrible.
And I was furious.
'Cause this is the first
time that I had saw
that there is a
media bias and a,
people call it propaganda,
people call it,
if they want something
to go in a certain way,
they have the power
and the tools to do so,
and to their discretion.
And so that was my first
instance of being like,
they're right.
People are telling the
truth about all this stuff.
(soft upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, we're
here at locals in Miami,
and joining me is a forward
for the Orlando Magic,
author of the book
"Why I Stand",
and founder of the new
clothing company UNITUS,
Jonathan Isaac.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Thank you for having me, man.
Glad to be here.
- I have to say you're the
first person we ever had
to move a table for,
and actually change some
of the situation that
we have going here.
People wanna know, most
importantly, 6'10"?
- 6'11".
- 6'11"!
- Really like seven
something with the hair,
but I'll be modest.
(Dave laughing)
- Does the hair
count on rebounding?
- No, it doesn't.
- It does not.
It's good to see, again,
we've done a couple
sit-downs over the years,
obviously NBA player
or author, as I said,
launching a new brand.
Just quick for the people
that don't know you,
gimme a little of the
Jonathan Isaac story,
getting you to the NBA,
and then we'll get
into the new stuff.
- Of getting into the NBA?
- Yeah, give me the life story
that gets you to the NBA,
and then we'll get
to what you're doing
these days.
- Super quick.
Like you said, name
Jonathan Isaac.
I grew up in Bronx, New
York, till I was about 10.
Played a little bit
of basketball there,
but it wasn't my thing.
Moved to Naples, Florida,
started to play a little
bit of organized basketball,
fell in love with it, kind
of put everything into it.
Became the number one player
in the state of Florida.
Went to Florida
State University.
I went to IMG for a year
before that, IMG Academy,
Florida State University,
and then was drafted six
pick to the Orlando Magic
back in 2017.
- And so now you've been
in the NBA, that's what?
Six seasons?
- Six seasons.
Couple injuries
along the way.
- Couple injuries, yes.
- But you're healthy now,
you finished the season.
- I'm ready to rock.
- You're ready to rock.
So this'll be really your first
season in a couple of years,
this upcoming season.
- First full season, yes.
I got to play a little bit
this past season coming back,
it is a big deal when
missing a lot of time,
but this is my first summer
of being actually able
to work out and not
just be rehabbing.
It feels good to actually
get in the gym and workout,
and looking forward to
this upcoming season.
- How does it feel to be
out as long as you were out,
and the ups and downs of
surgery, and all that stuff?
And you know I have
a torn ACL right now,
so out of four knees here,
you have the two good ones,
ironically, at least
mostly good, I guess.
But just mentally to like
get back on the court
after all that time
and everything.
How does that feel?
- It's tough,
it's tough.
It's terrible, honestly.
Going through it,
it's not just like you
going through an injury
kind of by yourself.
You're dealing with it,
you have the fans
are dealing with it,
the organization
is dealing with it,
fans, when are you gonna
come back and play?
Why aren't you playing?
So it's not something
that's easy to do.
And I know for a fact
that I wouldn't be able
to kind of press
my way through it
if it wasn't for one, my faith,
and then the people
that I have around me,
my wife, my family, my
pastor, my church family,
people to just encourage me
and help me to see the good
in every single situation
that I'm going through.
And that has me here.
And also, I think the
last point of that
is just being able to
identify with other people
who get injured now.
I have a new, I guess
perspective on injury,
and how much grit
and grind it takes,
and how you do get
to see who you are
when you're faced with that
kind of adversity as an athlete.
- What about the mental part?
When you get back on the court.
Your doc says, okay,
your knee's fine,
and you're like,
your body feels good,
'cause I can tell you
that I'm no NBA player,
but just from playing
with a weak knee,
it's more mental that
I'm always worried about
when I'm running
around out there
than the physical part in a way.
- Honestly, it's
like riding a bike.
I have heard that it's
very tough for certain guys
when you get back just
kind of trusting it.
For me, that really wasn't
my issue.
- You just trust the doc.
- Well, not the doc.
I just trust that
I'm ready to go.
My trust is in God,
and so I'm just like,
look, I'm healed, they say I'm
cleared, I'm ready to rock.
And I just kind of put one
foot in front of the other.
And once you get
the training wheels,
once you get like,
okay, I jumped, I fell,
and nothing happened,
you kind of just
forget about it.
But I do know that
for some people
it is very difficult to
get back on the court
after a big injury like that.
- So the thing that kind
of put you on the map
during Covid and all of
the BLM stuff and all that,
you stood for the
national anthem,
which was not that
popular at the time.
- At all.
(Jonathan laughing)
- When you look back on that,
do you think it was like,
well, I have no doubt that
you're proud of what you did,
but does it seem like a crazy
time to look back on that?
The bubble with the NBA?
Just the whole situation.
- Insane.
It's weird 'cause now like
kind of the dust has settled,
things have come out about
BLM and the organization,
the way that they handle
funds, and stuff like that.
So it's just like, it's not
as kind of potent right now,
but when you go back in
time, even Covid stuff,
it's died down, people
aren't as emotional about it,
but in the heat of it,
it was like Armageddon.
It was real.
So to be in that moment of
deciding on what I was gonna do,
how I was gonna handle the
pressure of the moment,
it really was, it
really, really, really,
really was tough.
- So then you do that,
and then kind of you
get welcomed by a
whole bunch of people
that maybe politically
you probably thought
maybe either weren't your people
or it was just like a
community of people,
you published your book
with The Daily Wire, right?
These were probably not
things you would've expected.
Can you talk about what
it was like to kind of
go in that direction,
so to speak?
- Yeah, I mean, so after I
decided to stand in a bubble,
and go through that entire
process, that was a-
- Were were you literally
the only player that did?
- No, one other player did.
I believe Meyers Leonard.
He did, I believe-
- Oh, he's not
even in the league anymore,
right?
- No, he's not in the league
anymore.
- That's interesting, there
was some other stuff there,
but he's young enough and
skilled enough to still be
in the league.
- No, I'm pretty sure
he can definitely play.
But yeah, so there was a ton
of negativity around the stand.
Obviously people were upset
about me deciding to stand,
and not kneel.
But then you talked about there
was an overwhelming support,
obviously, of Christians,
people who understood
the heartbeat of why I decided
to stand in the first place.
I never felt comfortable
with the tone
and the rhetoric of the Black
Lives Matter organization,
and I didn't want to
co-sign their message
by putting on their t-shirt.
And also I didn't wanna
co-sign their message
by kneeling.
And so there was that
kind of conservative folks
that obviously see this
kind of person standing up
for the flag, and they
kind of latched onto it.
But I tried my best to
stay true to my message of,
I believe that if we decide
all of us white, Black,
and different choose
to love each other,
like God loves us, which
is in spite of our sin,
instead of our shortcomings,
and realizing that we all
fall short of God's glory,
we could have real
progress and change.
And so that's what I stuck to,
but I wasn't negative towards
that kind of attention.
They definitely welcomed
me with open arms,
and being able to publish
a book with The Daily Wire,
I started to learn
about these people,
and they showed me love,
they showed me love.
- So they're not a
bunch of crazy racists?
- No, that's not
what I got from,
I would get questions about
why would you publish your book
with The Daily Wire?
They're all racist.
And I'm like, well, why
would they publish my book?
Obviously there is an
ideological similarity
that trumps skin
color in their eyes,
or they wouldn't
publish my book.
It would be like,
okay, we might agree
with him on some things,
but he's Black, not gonna do it.
So obviously that trumped
the color of my skin.
And even with Ben Shapiro
being an Orthodox Jew
and me being a Christian still
decided to publish my book.
And my book is like all about
Jesus at the end of the day.
- And you're 6'11"
and he's 4'2",
so there's a huge discrepancy.
- Yeah, very intimidating.
(Dave laughing)
And so, yeah.
So no, it was a great process,
very tough, like I said.
There was one moment,
and I tried my best to spell
this all out in the book,
but I was on the phone
with my pastor the night
before I decided to stand,
and I'm telling him,
I don't think you understand
how crazy this is gonna be.
I hadn't signed my contract yet,
I was up for an
extension that summer,
I knew I was gonna
be name called,
be ridiculed for it.
And he said to me,
you cannot stand for God
and God not stand for you.
And so that was kind
of the mic drop moment.
I was like, all
right, I'm doing it.
And we went full speed ahead.
- Yeah, and it's basically
worked since then.
You're doing a lot of stuff,
including you got a
new three-month old
in your life too.
- Yes, even talking
about doing stuff,
I never in a million
years would've thought
that I'd be an author.
So even when I get
introduced like that,
Jonathan Isaac, the
author, NBA player,
I'm like, what?
That still doesn't
make any sense to me.
But to be an author,
to have that come out
of this moment of standing,
it is really surreal.
And now I got a baby girl,
three months old.
- How's fatherhood
treating you?
(Jonathan sighing)
- I love it.
There's not many words for it,
or to try to put it into
its right perspective,
but it is that unconditional
love for something
that you know you're
responsible for.
And so it's been amazing.
- Yeah, so all of
this stuff happens,
you get some of the pushback,
now seeing some of
the dust settle,
the guys come up to you
now, and they're like,
hey, maybe I should
have done that,
or I respect what you did,
is there any of that kind stuff?
Or is everyone?
- Yeah, I've had plenty
of conversations,
not just for the BLM stuff,
but I would say even more
so for the Covid stuff.
- Right, that was the next-
- So it is something
that people forget,
but even that moment was like,
I'm the only player on my team,
and one of a handful
of guys in the NBA
that decided not
to get vaccinated.
And so that was-
- We'll throw to a video
of that right here,
so that people can see it again.
- I'm not anti-vax,
I'm not anti-medicine,
I'm not anti-science,
I didn't come to my
current vaccination status
by studying Black history,
or watching Donald
Trump press conferences.
I have nothing but
the utmost respect
for every healthcare worker
and person in Orlando,
and all across the world
that have worked tirelessly
to keep us safe.
My mom has worked in healthcare
for a really long time.
I thank God, I'm grateful
that I live in a society
where vaccines are possible,
and we can protect ourselves,
and have the means
to protect ourselves
in the first place.
But with that being
said, it is my belief
that the vaccine
status of every person
should be their own choice,
and completely up to
them without bullying,
without being pressured,
or without being
forced into doing so.
I'm not ashamed to say
that I'm uncomfortable
with taking the
vaccine at this time.
I think that we're
all different.
We all come from
different places.
We've all have had
different experiences
and hold dear to
different beliefs.
And what it is that
you do with your body
when it comes to putting
medicine in there
should be your choice
free of the ridicule
and the opinion of others.
- But was that completely
on the fly for you?
I mean, I guess everyone
was being asked questions
like that, but were you
planning on that moment?
- So this is what happened.
What happened was not
to take up too much time
on this topic, but
what happened was,
I had gone through
the whole thing,
I saw everything
that was going out.
People were being
crazy about Covid,
all these weird things about
why you should get a shot,
and incentivizing
you to get a shot.
And then obviously
you're getting bullied
if you even have any
questions about it,
natural immunity,
all that stuff.
- You didn't wanna do it
for the free hamburger?
- I'm like, if you're trying
to get somebody to do something
threatening them is only
gonna make them more weary.
I'm like, I don't
know what's going on,
but I decided not to do it.
And then Rolling Stone
put out an article,
it was something like
NBA's anti-vaxxer problem,
and they're pushing around the
league, and all that stuff.
And I had a call
with a journalist,
and it was all good faith,
oh, Jonathan, would love to
get your story, all this stuff.
And I'm telling him
about why my decision
not to get vaccinated.
And then the article
comes out, and it's like,
Jonathan Isaac waited
for people to die,
he put his trust in God,
all this different stuff.
I'm like, this is terrible.
And I was furious.
'Cause this is the first
time that I had saw
that there is a media bias,
and people call it
propaganda, people call it,
if they want something
to go in a certain way,
they have the power
and the tools to do so,
and to their discretion.
And so that was my first
instance of being like,
they're right, people
are telling the truth
about all this stuff, and so-
- Once you see that,
isn't it freaky?
- Yes.
- 'Cause no matter
how you see it,
no matter what leads you to
that moment of seeing it,
once you see it,
you can't unsee it.
- It's freaky, but
it's freeing too.
'Cause now I'm like, okay.
It's like, I had my moment of,
okay, I know what
all this means.
And so I was preparing myself
because I had media day coming
up literally the next day
after the article dropped.
So I knew I was
gonna get questions.
People were tweeting me,
telling me I'm crazy and stupid,
and all this stuff,
and I'm an anti-vaxxer.
And so I took that kind
of that night to be like,
okay, I know what it
is that I stand for,
I know why I did what I did,
and now taking it and kind
of just prepared myself,
and then I got the questions.
- Yeah, so the Covid
thing, the BLM thing,
the injury thing, all of
this stuff, fatherhood,
then you get back on the court
just for the end of the season.
I mean, that's like a lot of
stuff that that you kind of,
oh, you release a book.
I mean, and it's speaking
gigs, all that stuff,
just to get you to
just to what you love,
and what your main gig is.
It's pretty amazing.
- I mean, I just stayed busy.
I was rehabbing every day,
I was putting in the work,
but I had free time
on my hands to do,
and to think and create,
and just try my best to be an
inspiration to other people
who also found themselves
in this moment,
but didn't have either
the courage or the
people around them
to stand, and that's something
that it wasn't all me.
I had people around me
pushing me to be a light
to other people, and so
that's why a lot of the stuff
that I did, I decided to do it.
- Do you think you
were proven right,
not only on the Covid stuff,
but even on a lot
of the woke stuff?
And then this will sort of
get us to UNITUS in a sec.
But the NBA even has scaled
back on the woke stuff,
they had the BLM
logos on the court,
basically those are gone.
They seem like they've
shifted out of it.
The NHL, for example,
they're not gonna do
Pride night anymore.
Just these things that
they push on everybody,
it does seem like there's
been some reversal
with some of that.
- Yeah, 1,000%.
A 1,000% there is,
I think that it's just when
you get to these moments
of hostility and
everything is at the rise,
it is very easy to jump on,
we wanna support this,
and we wanna push this.
But when the dust does settle,
and kind of everybody kind of
comes back to their senses,
and okay, what is going on?
Where are things at?
I do think the kind of
rational thing to do is
to scale back and kind of
get back to program as usual.
And that's what a lot of
people and companies have done.
- I'm guessing most of
the players probably feel
that way too privately, right?
That they're just like,
I just wanna play ball,
more than anything else.
- I think even past players,
I think that's just
most Americans,
especially when it comes to
sports and entertainment,
they do just want to enjoy.
And I'm not saying that the
free choice for companies
to voice their opinion on issues
that they feel strongly
about is wrong,
I think that that's the
great thing about America,
people are free to do so,
but I do think that in
sport and entertainment,
there should be discretion
and there should be nuance
that the people that are
watching are not all the same,
they don't all believe
the same things,
and that should go
into your messaging
and what you decide
to put out there.
And not demonizing one set
of people, or one group,
or one side, but just trying
to share your view as a company
and as a person.
And I think at the same time,
if the league is
comfortable doing it,
they should then be
just as comfortable
allowing their
athletes to do it too,
even if it's in a way that
they don't agree with.
- Right, that seems to be
the part that the leagues
never get on board with, right?
The two-way street
portion of this thing.
So you mentioned Naples,
now you play for Orlando,
Florida guy,
according to the media
that you no longer trust,
I thought Florida's no
good for Black people.
- Stop it.
(both laughing)
- Isn't that what they tell us?
- I mean, I've been okay
here for a while, and-
- And you're not hiding,
you're not hiding at 6'11".
- Yeah, no, I mean,
look, no place is perfect.
Every place has their
ups and their downs,
but to espouse that Black
people can't be in Florida,
it is ridiculous.
And that's that kind of the
nuance that people don't,
everything is just so
polarizing these days,
you get the hits and you get
the controversy and the likes
by saying something
extremely controversial,
and then it goes everywhere.
One side is saying,
oh, I can't believe
they said that.
And the other side is trying
to back what the person said,
but obviously that's false
with the amount of African
Americans that live in Florida.
- You know what the
number one state
for Black-owned
small businesses?
- Is it Florida?
There you go.
- It is Florida, there you go.
So speaking of business,
you're starting UNITUS,
which now is going
to be basically,
well, you tell me, I don't
wanna put words in your mouth.
I was gonna say something.
You tell me what it's gonna be.
- So back in 2020,
same kind of around that time
of the BLM and the Covid,
I was a Nike-signed athlete,
and paid by Nike,
signed by Nike.
And after I got
injured, I ended up-
- How does that
process go by the way,
when you're drafted,
they're bringing in,
do all the shoe
companies come up to you,
and everybody's trying to
figure out who to go to?
Are you going to them?
- It depends largely
on who you wore
as a college athlete as well.
And so I've worn Nike
kind of my whole life
once I got into basketball,
so I was in the EYBL,
which is Nike's kind
of youth AAU circuit.
So I was always wearing
Nike then, loved it.
When I got to Florida State,
Florida State's a Nike
school, got to the league.
Well, when transitioning
into the league,
I was courted by Adidas for a
while, but no other companies.
I was kind of adamant about
I wanna be a Nike guy.
And ended up signing with them.
And it was great.
Like I love Nike, and I have
loved Nike for a long time,
I disagree with them and
a lot of other companies
have kind of made
conscious decisions
over the last few years to
move in a specific direction,
this is what they're
saying that they're for.
And when it comes to UNITUS,
for me it's just about
freedom, it's just about,
look, these companies
are allowed to do it,
just like I talked about the
organizations like the NBA,
but we're also free to
support what we wanna support.
And if I could create something
that stands up for family,
faith, freedom, and
the values and ideals
that one has made
this country great,
has made this country prosper,
and have the progress that
it has had from its founding,
and then just stay true to
who I am as a Christian man,
and athlete, and person.
I want those values to be
celebrated in the marketplace
and in the culture, and
what better way to do that
than through really
cool, awesome clothing?
- Yeah, so it's an
athletic wear brand that-
- Athletic wear
and leisure wear.
- [Dave] And leisure wear,
so we'll show some images
while we're talking right now.
How does this even begin?
How does this happen?
That one day-
- Yeah, great question.
- [Dave] Did you have the idea
and then you go to somebody?
Did somebody come to you?
- No, no no.
I'll tell you, so my pastor's
a huge part of my life.
Like I told you, I was
on the phone with him
the night before I decided
to stand in a bubble.
But just talking to him,
and he was the reason why
I wrote the book as well.
He comes rushing over to
my house one day and says,
people know your stand, but
they don't know your story.
And that was the
thing of saying,
you need to write a book,
and you need to do a movie,
all this different stuff.
- Is the movie coming?
- We've been in talks
for quite a while.
But if anybody wants to do
the "Why I Stand" movie,
hit me up.
- All right.
- But yeah, so after I
didn't re-sign with Nike,
talking to him, he says,
you should look into
creating your own shoe,
something that stands
for your values,
and that you can use for you.
It wasn't necessarily something
that could be broadcast
this to everybody,
and I said, I don't
think you understand
how hard it is to create a shoe.
This isn't easy.
(Dave laughing)
And I've learned
how difficult it is
to create a high-value,
high-performance shoe.
But to his guidance,
I kind of said,
I'll set out and see
what it looks like,
had some conversations, and
then was like, I'm gonna do it.
And that vision of just
creating a shoe for myself
to wear during the
season turned into,
there are so many people
that believe like I believe,
and as I see the decline
of these values and ideals
that I believe deserve
to be celebrated
as I see their decline in
the marketplace and culture,
why not give these people
something for them?
Give them a home, build
a community of people
that are saying, we
love these values,
and we stand on these values.
And I think with
being the only person
to do a couple of things,
I do know how lonely it is
to do something by yourself.
And I know that the fear aspect
and the intimidation aspect
of everything that's going on
around you is very daunting.
And so if I can help people
have a sense of pride
about their values and ideals,
and be able to wear
it on their sleeve,
I think that's something
that's beautiful,
and American, and free.
And so that vision started
to kind of bounce
around in my head,
and he came up with
the name UNITUS,
and we were just kind
of playing with it,
and from there I've
just been kind of
executing in the background,
not saying anything to anybody.
- So what do you do?
Was the first idea,
okay, I'm gonna
create the shoe first?
- Yeah, the shoe started first.
So I am gonna be debuting a
shoe at some point this summer
that I will be wearing
this upcoming season.
It's called the Judah One,
gonna be five colorways,
each colorway has
a different verse,
Bible verse that goes with
the colorway and the shoe.
But that's not necessarily
UNITUS just yet.
One of the things about
UNITUS is I wanna be able
to sign athletes from all
different sports as we grow,
value aligned athletes
to be ambassadors
and forward runners for
the company and brand.
I'm gonna be the first signed
athlete to the company,
and so that sneaker is
gonna fall under Judah
that is signed to UNITUS.
And so it started there
and then it looked like,
okay, what is it?
- And were you there?
At the factory, telling
'em this is what I want,
I want this weight, I want-
- I'll tell you there's a
company called SoleWorks,
they're ex-Nike
guys, ex-Adidas guys
that have kind of come
together and said,
we wanna do one-off
shoes for certain people,
so they're doing
Marshawn Lynch's cleat,
I think they did a
shoe for Pharrell
or something like that as well.
And so I got hooked up
with them and I said,
I don't know anything about
this field or this industry,
and they did, so we
kind of linked up,
and were able to come into
some type of partnership,
and the shoe's being
made out of Vietnam.
And so they've been
going back and forth,
and sending me
videos and photos,
and the design
process took forever.
But it took pretty much
an entire year to be able
to get a, this is what we
wanted the shoe to look like,
this is what we
wanted to feel like,
to have the prototypes, all
that stuff, and now we're here.
- Right, right.
Are you involved in making
sure that the process
being made in Vietnam,
all that stuff,
obviously Nike
gets a lot of flack
for some of their practices,
how involved are you
in that kind of thing?
- 1,000%.
They've assured me, they've
gone back and forth,
that this is an
upstanding factory,
I was very adamant about
not desiring to manufacture
in China and trying to
find sourcing otherwise.
And we were able to, so
I'm happy about that.
- That must have been complex.
'Cause I feel like
everything's made out of China
these days.
- Everything is made
out of China, but for
clothing and stuff,
there's great
factories in Turkey,
and a lot of the
embroidering and stitching
is done right here in America.
- Yeah, okay, so you
launch with the shoe,
and then over the fall then
a bunch of the other products
will come out?
- So on August 1st,
people will be able
to buy leisure wear.
And so that's gonna be
t-shirts, hoodies, sweatpants,
jackets, stuff like that.
And then as we move
through the fall,
there's gonna be a sportswear
drop for men and women.
There's also kids that's
gonna be available
in the leisure wear as well.
And as we get closer
to the season,
we'll drop the sneaker.
And then the hope is that
we'll be able to build on this
and training shoes, running
shoes, walk around shoes,
everything like that, and
kind of off into the sunset.
- Do you view your
basketball career in some way
as just the vehicle that
then became the thing to do
all of this other stuff?
I mean, not only the company,
but the spiritual stuff
and everything else?
- I would say to a degree.
I love basketball.
I love playing it.
I loved the game ever
since I was a kid,
but it has become what
I do and not who I am.
I found my identity in Christ
and I just try my best to use
that as a platform for who I am.
And I love the game, I can't
wait to get back to it.
I'm getting ready to
have a great season,
I'm looking forward to it.
But again, I try to use it as
a vehicle to portray who I am
as an individual over basketball
being the end-all be-all
to Jonathan Isaac.
- Do you get any pushback
on the controversial stuff
any more?
- Do I?
'Cause sometimes I find people
after you've been
through it enough,
and you've hit big ones, right?
Covid, flag, America,
you've hit not just
minor ones, big ones,
but sometimes you get
to the other side,
and then there's a
certain type of person
just completely moves on,
and another type of
person kind of stays
in that craziness for a while.
- Well, I definitely
still get it.
I think that my skin
has gotten a bit thicker
where it's just like,
I know who I am,
and I'm gonna let
you know who I am
and what it is
that I believe in,
and you're free to
like that or not.
But I'm gonna be
authentic to myself.
And so I definitely
still get pushback.
I definitely I can't
tweet something
without getting a tweet back
(Dave laughing)
about what somebody thinks
about me, which is fine.
But yeah, definitely
going through the course,
and kind of going
through the wringer of
what does it look
like to be attacked
and have your name kind of
dragged through the mud,
and it does make you a
stronger, more resilient person.
- Yeah, I'm just thinking
of this on the fly,
but another guy who has said
a lot of controversial things,
another one that's no longer
in league is Enes Kanter,
who certainly skill wise,
the guy was averaging
a double double,
I think his last season,
I mean, he should
be in the league.
So that must've been
sitting with you
for a lot of this too, right?
- Well, yeah, even
back during BLM,
I told you I hadn't
signed my contract yet,
so I already knew that
this could be something
that derails that,
because of, you never know about
possibility of being
blackballed from the NBA,
that there's a chance
of that happening,
or your organization
or somebody high up
that you don't even know says,
we don't want that guy
on our team anymore.
I'm sure it has happened
behind closed doors,
and we don't know about it,
but even possibly
in that situation,
you don't know what
transpired for him
not to be in the
league any more.
But it was definitely a
thought in the back of my mind
that this could be
the end of my career,
but just kind of piggybacking
on what my pastor told me,
you can't stand for God
and God not stand for you.
I stood, I was able
to sign my contract,
and keep moving
forward the magic.
- Yeah, so you must
have a real love
for the Orlando organization,
I would imagine.
- I've got major respect.
- 'Cause most wouldn't have.
I mean, I think
that's pretty obvious.
- I've got major respect, I
was their first draft pick,
John Hammond and Jeff Wellman,
I was their first pick.
And so they've done right by me,
they show me love even through
all the controversial stuff.
And so I definitely have
a great respect for 'em.
- Yeah, what else is next?
Well, I guess the movie's next,
you're working on the movie,
I feel like we're gonna
do this every year,
and every year you're gonna
have another major project.
- What's next is just
having a great season
and seeing UNITUS take off,
hoping that people obviously
love what it looks like.
That's a huge thing, I
wanted it to be something
that's culturally relevant
and that young people,
adults, kids, they
wanna wear it.
Obviously, that's great.
But even more so I want to
see the message of believing,
and finding pride and
encouragement in our values.
I wanna see that propagated.
I wanna see that grow
through ever what
vehicle that is,
I believe that
UNITUS is a vehicle
that can stand the test of time,
and have people feel
that way about the brand
and the company, and
that's all I'm looking for.
- Do you have certain
athletes in different sports
that you're talking to?
Or you kind of have
your eye on them?
Like the type of guy
I can talk to or?
- I've got a few, I've had
some great conversations
with different guys.
I won't name 'em.
I think by the time
this comes out,
people will already know,
but Riley Gaines is
gonna be our kind of
first brand ambassador.
- Awesome.
- So she'll be at
the event as well.
She's not swimming anymore,
but she's a firehouse
for what she's stood for
and been able to do
in women's sports,
and looking forward to seeing
her kind of career in speaking
and everything
like that take off.
And so she's awesome.
- Yeah, it never stops.
They'll always find
another one for you, right?
There's just always
another controversy,
and another guy that'll
hopefully do the right thing.
- Yes.
- Yeah, how involved are you in
not just the shoes
which you talked about,
but all the clothing,
athletic wear, etc.,
in terms of design and all that?
Like to keep it,
- I'm super involved.
- To keep it as relevant
as you said?
- I'm super involved.
It's definitely
something that I try
to knock out in my free time.
Meetings, and calls,
and stuff like that,
but I'm healthily involved
to where I can still do
what I gotta do,
but also steer this thing in a
way that sticks to the vision
that I set out for it to be.
- I don't say this
to many guests,
but you're basically
living my dream.
You're in the NBA,
and you're doing
a zillion other things.
- I know you love the hoop,
so I appreciate that.
- That you love,
that you love.
All right, next time we're
doing this at my house
so we can get that
one-on-one game going.
Okay, alright, cool.
- I'll make that happen.
- I'll take it,
I'll take it.
- Wait, how old are you?
How old are you?
- 25.
- So I'm 47, so you
got 22 years on me.
You got about a foot and a half,
and you got two good knees.
It's not really fair.
- You won't score.
- Can you play NBA live?
Can we try that, maybe?
- No, I'm actually not
very good at that stuff,
(Dave laughing)
but you'll probably beat
me in that for sure.
- If I could get an H on
you, that would be enough.
- Okay, HORSE?
You're probably good
at HORSE, though.
- I can shoot, I
can shoot still.
- Okay.
- That's the last thing to go,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, right.
We'll see, we'll see then.
- It's good to see you anyway.
- Thank you, Dave.
Appreciate it.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our Politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our Full Episode playlist.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.